wir schauen direkt hier in die
hauptstadt g7 protestmittel hier in
berlin an die 100 klima chaoten haben
das finanzministerium blockiert alle
eingänge sind verschlossen 20 protestler
kleben an türen und einfahrten der
betrieb des ministeriums ist natürlich
erheblich gestört die protestler fordern
schuldners für den globalen süden und
wir wollen von unserem reporter viktor
wachs wissen wie die lage jetzt in
diesen minuten vor ort ist victor kleben
die protestler noch an scheiben und
fenstern
leider die nicht hören doch jetzt jetzt
bin ich wieder da sandra gehören gegnern
wunderbar also ich stehe hier vom
wunderbar ich stehe hier vorm
bundesfinanzministerium in ihr könnt
sehen hinter mir also hier sind noch
einige leute da es haben sich zahlreiche
menschen angeklebt an allen eingängen
des ministeriums im laufe des tages die
polizei musste sie dann los machen und
zwar hat sie dafür verwendet ein ganz
normales speiseöl denn wenn man eine
bestimmte chemische lösung verwenden
will um diese leute ab zu machen braucht
man einen richterlichen erlass und den
zu bekommen hat eine ganze weile
gedauert den ganzen morgen und deswegen
kleben hier jetzt immer noch leute hier
neben mir sieht man die menschen die
bereits abgemacht wurden die herren hier
noch aus warten was passieren wird ob
sie in gewahrsam genommen werden oder
nicht auch das ist noch nicht klar und
hier vorne ganz am ende ganz am eingang
sieht man die menschen die weiterhin
angeklebt sind die entfernt werden unter
verwendung eben von bestimmten mitteln
von öl
könnte als die lage dramatisch bickel du
kannst selbst am besten einschätzen von
dort denn mit diesem speiseöl wir kennen
das ja auch mittlerweile schon fast
täglich muss man sagen hier in der
hauptstadt von den autobahnen im
berufsverkehr das immer wieder eine
aktion auf die die klima chaoten
zurückgreifen wie lange dauert ist sie
da überhaupt los zu bekommen die beamten
sind teilweise stundenlang im einsatz
und die arbeit des ministeriums
erheblich gestört
so ist es die beamten sind stundenlang
im einsatz ist es wahnsinnig heiß hier
in berlin über 30 grad und diese
menschen mit öl ab zu machen dauert
einfach viel länger als mit dieser
lösung denn diese lösung hat das ist ein
chemisches ich war nicht besonders gut
informiert aber irgendwann in italien
macht sie sofort ab aber der
richterlichen erlass ist in diesem fall
jetzt noch nicht da und deswegen müssen
direkt mit sonnenblumenöl speiseöl
kernöl die ganze zeit herum stapeln und
das ist eine ganz komische stimmung ist
ganz still die beamten und die klima
chaoten die da sozusagen ganz nahe
körperlich aneinander sind sprechen gar
nicht miteinander während sie das
stundenlang aber so nah aneinander in
dieser hitze verbringen und abgelöst
werden und victor wir sehen auch nicht
nur wir sind mit einem kameramann vor
ort sondern auch die polizei
dokumentiert alles fleißig mit im
hintergrund sag mal gegen wen oder was
richtet sich dieser protest denn
überhaupt genau
ja sandra was der plan ist dass die
g7-staaten dem so genannten globalen
süden die schulden erlassen die idee ist
folgende globales süden muss in fossile
energien investieren die zu erstellen
das klima denn der globale süden
schuldet dem westen zu viel geld dh die
logik dieser aktivisten ist wenn denen
das geld erlassen wird wenn die schulden
erlassen werden können sie in
erneuerbare energien investieren das ist
die idee hinter der ist auch haben mit
einer aktivistin gesprochen wir wollen
mal hören was sie dir gesagt hat
bei mir ist amelie sie ist die
kommunikationschefin dieser aktion
amelie vielen dank dass du mit uns
spricht man sieht seine mitstreiter
hinter dir was motiviert euch dass sie
zu tun ja vor allem also mich persönlich
motiviert dass ich immer wieder in den
nachrichten
höre und sehe wie schlimm ist im
globalen sind schon aussieht wir haben
ja hier auch schon zahlreiche
auswirkungen der klimakrise die wir
spüren gerade jetzt in berlin ist hitze
alarm und im in indien pakistan da sind
die temperaturen sogar sterben menschen
täglich aber fangen wir den leuten die
im finanzministerium arbeiten hier zu
spät zur arbeit gekommen sind ja dass
sie sich dafür einsetzen sollen das eben
der schuldenerlass im globalen süden
passiert wir haben durch zivilen
ungehorsam schon zahlreiche
veränderungen in der welt geschaffen und
deswegen machen wir das jetzt hier auch
weiter und genau die die menschen die
hier im finanzministerium arbeiten die
können an ihren chef an christian
lindner appellieren der sitz im iwf der
kann sich dafür einsetzen beim treffen
der g 7 und genau das eben die schulden
erlassen werden für den globalen süden
ist es dann aber wirklich richtig dafür
das gesetz zu brechen ja also die die
letzten jahre haben gezeigt dass
klassischer protest petition nicht
ausreichen deswegen bin ich sicher dass
wir in den zivilen ungehorsam gehen
müssen für für dieses thema für
klimagerechtigkeit und ich persönlich
möchte auch nicht weiterhin teil dieses
systems sein oder bei diesem system
einfach so mitmachen was eben diese
ausbeutung im globalen süden weiter
voranschreitet da sterben menschen für
unseren wohlstand und das kann ich so
nicht akzeptieren
deswegen glaube ich habe ich auch das
recht mich auf die straße zu setzen
eingängen zu blockieren denn weiter so
ist nicht mehr möglich
ziviler ungehorsam viktor so nennen die
klima chaoten das was sie machen dass
sachbeschädigungen ist es auch intensiv
in das leben aller menschen eingreift
wenn sie beispielsweise die autobahnen
blockieren was ist aus den gesprächen
heraus hören können wie weit sind sie
bereit diesen sogenannten zivilen
ungehorsam voranzutreiben
patricia die leben in einer kompletten
parallelen realität ich habe mit vielen
gesprochen ich habe sie gefragt was es
mit den leuten die zu spät zur arbeit
kommen was es mit den müttern die oder
mit den vätern die ihre kinder in eine
kita bringen wollen was ist mit leuten
die zu ihren kranken verwandten wollen
und die haben gesagt ein tod muss man
sterben dieses zitat habe ich mehrmals
bekommen es ist ihnen völlig egal
kick backs für uns vor dem
finanzministerium hier in berlin wo sich
klima aktivisten fest geklickt haben
ersten dank viktor